see if you know any of the well this is
a test channel right do you know if
there is any plans for any 4k releases
for the older Marvel movies yes
okay is there a phase three box set
coming uh I don't know about that but I
would like to buy one let me know if you
find out well the big question of course
is now that phase three like a
spider-man is part of Phase three but
when that's done is there any sort of
plan for some epic 20 to film 20 I don't
like 23 films yeah box set right
everything yeah I guess we sort of have
to write I think and design like a
really cool case where the questions
really even come with the right case
that we wait the case will be like big
well yes okay the right case for Phase
one it's like a briefcase - it's the or
the case but by the way it going back to
your other question we are going to
remaster all of our films in the 4k
we're in the process of doing that so
it's all happening because but I'm also
curious about obviously Disney Plus is
coming yes I am tremendously looking
forward to this thing but does that
impact the home video releases at all or
is it still gonna be you know physical
media for the future movies you know
like spider-man whatever it may be like
or will it you know what I mean like how
does that work Disney Plus I don't think
that the physical DVD itself will ever
go away
I don't think so if that's happening
they haven't told us but you will be
able to actually click Disney Plus and
there she is